you're not only one of the main
proprietors of one of the biggest
traffic blogs on the web what were you
doing ten years ago I was running call
centres for the alarm industry i am nick
gillespie for reason TV and yes I have a
mustache today we're talking to with ed
morrissey of hot air ed thanks for
joining my pleasure ed tell us about hot
air hot air is it's a it's a booming
business at hot air I've been there
since februari of 2008 so I'm coming up
in three years that we have about
tripled the readership but it's been
it's been a great ride for me you hot
air showcases video as well as blogging
by yourself and I'll abundant and a
couple other people I'll abundant will
you name him I will not although I will
say that the rumor that nick gillespie
is all a pundit is absolutely i'm
totally not true not true not true what
is the essence of hot air what makes for
a good hot air story it's an interesting
question because we just got done doing
the top 50 most reviewed posts of 2010
it was actually rather surprising mix a
lot of people went into it thinking that
you know the top 20 of those were going
to be all sarah palin posts so it turned
out only for the top 50 we're about
Sarah Palin I think five or six of them
about Chris Christie I think it has to
do with the timeliness of the event or
the the person that we're covering and I
certainly think it has something to do
with the commentary we're providing on
it but I think timeliness and in video
is important what are the politics of
hot air how do you define them I would
say that the politics of hot air our
center-right conservative conservative
libertarian sort of fusion I think both
olive pundit and I have have libertarian
flavor to the conservative viewpoint
that weekend you've also started writing
a column for the week Yeah right news
magazine what's that about and what what
type of stuff will you be covering the
week wanted to have a more
straightforward conservative point of
view they have a really great lineup
called the bullpen and they felt that
they needed a strong conservative voice
to be part of that in order to provide
balance because they have some really
good talented writers area robert sturm
is obviously from the left you've got
David from you've got the open sort of
doing the no lay
Bulls thing now and you've got Francis
wilkinson a number of people that are
really excellent writers at the bullpen
so I'm very excited to be there and i
plan on basically presenting the same
type of viewpoint and a little bit
longer form s a really good thing rather
than the blog post where you the excerpt
and commentary excerpt and commentary
more just straightforward column writing
there so it's exciting i'm looking
forward to it let's talk a little bit
about your your background because
you're not only one of the main
proprietors of one of the biggest
traffic blogs on you know on the web but
you also are a kind of the
personification of the opportunities
that are afforded by a decentralized
more democratized form of media what
were you doing 10 years ago 10 years ago
i was running call centers for the alarm
industry which is an all-encompassing or
usually is an all-encompassing task and
it's a 24-7 type of job but you know
everybody gets down time and about a
little over seven years ago I started
dabbling in doing some writing on
politics I've always been interested in
politics always been in been a new
suppose you was your first blog the
captains quarters captain squirters was
my first blog yeah that started in
October of 2003 and honestly the reason
the reason why I started it then was my
wife was in the hospital I had some free
time on my hands and so it was like
whatever the alarm calls came in you
would just turn them off so that you
could have some me time officially
speaking officially speaking I did this
on my own time that's the story I'm
sticking to so you went from captain's
quarters to hot air originally live from
captain's quarters to blogtalkradio we
kept captain's quarters going but I was
hired by blogtalkradio worked for
slightly less than a year really
interesting concept of blogtalkradio
very again a technology that give us a
type of radio show to anybody with the
phone and an internet connection so it's
again the lowering of the depredations
let's let's say the low it lowering of
quality standards as well as a barrier
stands but when you lower barriers to
entry that's you get a whole lot of
variety diversity which is what's good
about that same things true in the
blogosphere the republicans have just
taken over the house of
of representatives for the first time in
a few years what jazz is you up about
that and what makes you sweat a little
bit what jazz is me up about that is
that by taking control of the house as
opposed to taking control of the Senate
by itself the Republicans have an
opportunity to cut funding to government
agencies that don't deserve funding
reduced funding to government agencies
that really nice three that a fit into
that I think at least in terms of the
leash I think you gotta have to take me
looking at the FCC the EPA pretty almost
anything that dabbles in the interstate
commerce Wickard versus filburn area
really needs to have their funding
either reduced or eliminated the
difficulty of course is that because
they don't have the Senate and because
they don't have the White House
expectations may be a little overblown
at this point as to exactly what the
Republicans can accomplish you are based
on Minneapolis yes what are the benefits
of being far outside the beltway and I
won't say the real America but you're
far outside the Beltway does that help
or hurt your perspective well I think
it's I think it just gives you a
different perspective I think it gives
you a perspective of how things are
playing that or farther outside of the
media bubble in Washington DC there was
a really interesting article in the
washington post it and I like the
Washington Post but I really ripped this
article because the article was the
Republicans are going to take over the
house and the economy in the local area
is going to crash because spending won't
be going on here well that may sound
interesting to people inside DC but it's
the money that's coming from every place
else that is inflating that bubble that
really needs to be deflated if it's if
it's based on government subsidies and
so I think it's interesting to have that
kind of a perspective whereas if i was
living in DC I might be saying yeah you
know the economy might be hurt by this
it be I think distance has its drawbacks
as well I think you're not necessarily
as well connected to some of the things
that are some of the undercurrents that
are going on some of the behind the
scenes things that are going on in
Washington DC you have to make up for
that by trying to cultivate connections
from people who are here and looking for
really good reporters who are doing
really good work what is the biggest
the issue do you think that divides
conservatives and libertarians I think
there's a few and in these are issues
that you struggle with because as a
conservative you are looking at the
concept of limited government as a
foundational principle but then
conservatives tend to want to have
government run things like say in just
using one example definitions of
marriage which libertarians would
dispute there are things that
conservatives want to spend money on the
government level that libertarians may
have an issue with I think one of the
interesting things that are going to
come up is and it was right about this
today is the issue of cutting spending
at the pentagon which i think is not
necessarily a libertarian point of view
but i think the idea of limited
government and drives that to some
extent i think that we have to take a
look at our role strategically in the
world and I think there are places that
we don't necessarily have to be anymore
i'm not sure that we have to be have
this big huge heavy footprint in europe
and supporting european secure and let's
say is that you don't even think we
should be in rhode island to you I think
we should defend Rhode Island Rhode
Island should be defended even even with
lincoln Chafee and charge from and I
think we should defend Rhode Island well
I want to thank ed morrissey of hot air
calm and of the week congratulations on
the new column thanks for talking to
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie